james counted the number of alligators
in various local bodies of water and
graph the results
how many fewer alligators are in bite
swamp than chomp lake and reptile creek
combine
so down here we have this bar graph that
james somehow survived to create after
going to all these bodies of water and
counting the alligators we'll hope he
was behind a fence or something
so then we're asked
how many fewer alligators are in bite
swamp
than in chomp lake and reptile creek
combined
so we need to know first how many are in
chomp lake and reptile creek combined
before we can figure out how many fewer
are in bite swamp
so let's look down here here's chomp
lake sounding super scary
and its bar lines up to six so there's
six alligators in chomp lake
plus
in reptile creek if we go over here to
reptile creek
this bar lines up to nine so there's
nine alligators hanging out in reptile
creek
six plus nine
let's see nine plus one
is ten so we can make our six into a
five and a one
nine plus one is ten plus five more
equals fifteen
so there's a total of fifteen alligators
in chomp lake and reptile creek combined
now we can answer how many fewer than 15
are in bite swamp
so bite swamp down here sounding the
most dangerous of them all
has a bar that lines up to 12.
so 12 there's 12 alligators in bite swap
so how many fewer is 12
than the amount in chomp lake and
reptile creek combined 15. so how much
fewer is 12 than 15.
well if we have 15 and we take 12 away
that leaves us with
three
there are three fewer alligators in bite
swamp than there are in chomp lake and
reptile creek combined